[موسيقى]
العمليات القوات المشتركه صعبه على اي شيء
في اي وقت لذلك عندما نشاهد تحديات مهمه
عبور نهر وهي اصعب عمليه قوات المشتركه
دائما ستبدا قبيحه للمشاهدين من غير اصحاب
الخبره الامر
لاي مشكله تقريبا
السبب هو ان العمليه المشتركه يجب ان تتم
بشكل افضل وعلى الدبابات ومنظومات الدفاع
الجوي مثلا وجميع القوات العمل
[موسيقى]
هناك اهميه كبيره في الكلام الذي سمعناه
على سبيل المثال السابق كلامي اوكرانيا في
شهر فبراير وفي الوقت نفسه لاعتقد ان
الغرب يفهم كلام بوتين فيما يخص معاناه
الاستنزاف والقدره على تحمله كما ان علينا
ان نجد طريقه ذلك
[موسيقى]
حرب الاستنزاف تستنظيفه
وذخيره اكثر من ما توقعوا اي شخص على ذلك
افاده التقارير بان امريكا منحت نحو
ثمانيه الاف الصاروخ جافلين الاوكرانيين
والقاعده الصناعيه الامريكيه تصنع هذه
الصواريخ سنويا
[موسيقى]